the Vatican announced this morning that
Pope Francis will meet priests sex abuse
victims during a weekend visit to
Ireland Cardinal Sean O'Malley of Boston
apologized last night for how
allegations that disgraced Cardinal
Theodore McCarrick was an abuser were
not addressed by his office only on CBS
this morning Pastor Boniface Ramsey
tells how he repeatedly complained to
senior church officials about the
retired Archbishop of Washington making
Batista's covering the clergy abuse
scandal Nicki good morning good morning
Cardinal O'Malley the mission is all the
more startling because he has perhaps
the Pope's most trusted adviser on
stopping sex abuse O'Malley says he had
no idea someone had complained about
McCarrick and that he never saw that
letter I had the impression that
virtually everybody knew about it
father Boniface Ramsey says he first
heard about Cardinal Theodore McCarrick
disturbing behavior as early as 1986
Archbishop McCarrick was inviting
seminarians to his beach house there
were five beds and there were six people
Archbishop McCarrick arranged it in such
a way that somebody would join him in
his bed Ramsey now a pastor in New York
City wrote a letter in June 2015 to
Cardinal Sean O'Malley who had just been
appointed by Pope Francis to lead a
commission to protect children from sex
abuse Ramsey wrote some of these stories
were not presented to me as mere rumors
but were told to me by persons directly
involved response that I got was from
his secretary which said that this
really does not fall under our
jurisdiction
Cardinal O'Malley said that was a
mistake in retrospect he said I should
have seen that letter precisely because
it made assertions about the behavior of
an archbishop in the church O'Malley
told Norah O'Donnell in 2014 the church
took sex abuse complaints seriously
certainly the Holy Father is very very
aware of that and very committed
to zero tolerance and responding in a
proper way
yesterday the Pope once again apologized
to survivors the heart-wrenching pain of
these victims which cries out to heaven
was long ignored he said but their
outcry was more powerful than all the
measures meant to silence it Greg Burke
is a spokesman for the Vatican
Francis says greater accountability is
needed urgently not only for those who
committed these crimes but also for
those who cover them up which in many
cases means bishops father Ramsey told
us he brought his concerns about
Cardinal McCarrick to the Vatican's
attention in 2015 years before he went
to O'Malley mckarrick responded to the
allegations saying he maintains his
innocence also yesterday embattled
Cardinal Donald Wuerl who was at the
center of last week's explosive
Pennsylvania grand jury report met
privately in Washington with priests on
his archdiocese advisory group whorl was
also accused of shielding 32 predatory
priests when he was bishop of pittsburgh
so constant every day new shocking
allegations we know the Pope will be
meeting with some of these victims this
weekend in Ireland yes and many want
questions about what the church is going
to do rather than just voice outrage and
concern about it what steps they're
going to take survivors want concrete
steps laid out and this is the latest
chapter they wanted concrete steps long
before to and they were taken Nikki
thank you